it truly is an honor to be back here
this evening to share with you this
wonderful moment acting which comes from
the heart deserves recognition as actors
we strive for it by nominating the
following actors for Best Performance in
a leading role you have honoured each
one magnificently the nominees for Best
Actor in a motion picture Oh William
hunt in tattoos
Macker
robbing women kids
Morello must be on the inter-gang
making him
and the winner is
thank you thank you all very much i I
really want to thank the actors branch
the Academy first for just being a
nominee with four actors and I really
admire at least one that I consider a
really good friend who I admire and
thank you for that and for this fellow
from all of the Academy I just want to
share it with all the good work that was
done by all the branches whether you
were nominated or not tonight but this
is all with you a large part of this
award belongs to Oliver Stone and not
only as the director but having the
courage to cast me in a part that not
many people thought I could play so I'll
always be eternally grateful to him for
that and as a writer Oliver with Stanley
Weiser wrote a part that was the best
part that I've ever had in my career -
Charlie and Martin Sheen - wonderful
actors that happen to be father and son
I thank them all very much for their
help at Pressman Alix our producers
Leonard Goldberg Scott Rudin Tom Sharda
Fox I thank you too
I'd like to dedicate this award to
William Garrard Diana Douglas Garrard
and Douglas and Kirk Douglas
my parents and stepparents who have been
extremely supportive and loving to me
over the years in particular to my
father who I don't think ever missed one
of my college productions for his
continued support and for helping a son
step out of the shadow I'll be eternally
grateful to you dad for that too
Bonni to my my wife diandra and all my
old friends were smiling with me tonight
thank you and do all your movie buffs I
just really appreciate for making this a
wonderful moment for me thank you and
good night Cameron I love you